so as these teachers demand billions of
dollars to run their school my next
guest at just 22 years old has been
finding his own resources and donations
in order to open a charter school for
young black men in orlando
king randall is the founder of the x for
boys and he joins me now you've seen
them before king uh your quick reaction
to what's happening across the country
and why it inspired you
to do what you're doing right now which
is taking the power away from government
even though the government tried to shut
you down you had the superintendent down
there in atlanta to try to
get his cronies to shut you down but now
you have the power
to go directly to the kids have the
parents to go directly to the kids
through your school talk about it
absolutely well lawrence i've been
working with children for the past three
years and when i began working with the
children seeing them not be able to read
seeing them not be able to write i
became alarmed i mean i was wondering
why and how these kids were being passed
through school these kids are in high
school and middle school etc and these
kids can't read and write and when i say
can't read and write i mean literally
just that and i'm wondering why these
kids can't read and write and i'm going
to look at the statistics and right now
only 19 of our high school children are
being proficient in math when they
graduate just under 30 of those children
are being proficient in reading so we're
they're telling you know oh we have the
super high graduation rate and these
children are being illiterate they're
graduating functionally illiterate and
one thing i want to say you know it's so
many of us that love to say that the
teachers don't want to teach et cetera
it's not even that it's that these
teachers are also handcuffed to the same
system teachers also need school choice
too nobody stands up for teachers when
they need assistance as well these
teachers don't feel safe at school
sometimes just like as the children
don't i just heard joe biden say that
the children are safe at school children
are not safe at school these kids are
still smoking at school these kids are
having sex at school these kids are
doing crazy things at school and these
teachers are also being violently
assaulted at school etc but these
stories don't hit the the news these
stories don't come anywhere because
anytime a teacher says something it gets
brushed under the world but you let a
child say something that a teacher did
then that teacher gets an indictment and
it's all over the news etc nobody stands
up for teachers but this is why school
choice in schools like ours are so
important because we have to give
teachers an option we have to give
students an option we have to give
parents an option because parents are
having trouble especially single moms
who are working and they need schooling
for their children they're expecting the
school to be teaching their children to
read to be teaching their children to
write and these kids are 14 15 years old
and their parents to discover that they
can't read we have such a toxic
relationship with these systems in our
community we'll allow our pastors and uh
certain politicians in our community to
come up with all these strategic ways
for us to continue
government
for everything else and i'm just like no
let's use that same ingenuity to teach
our people how to do something for
ourselves sometimes we have to put a
period where we always add in a comma
you know king
how does it happen
that when the kids come to you they
can't read and write somebody passed
them through how does that happen
it's the system
i have teachers email me all the time i
wish i could put the emails up and let
the teachers remain anonymous so many
teachers in my local school system will
contact me and say they're telling us
basically to pass the kids through
school they're literally telling them to
push the kids through school these kids
can't read and write and they're
wondering why we have one of the highest
crime rates uh in the in this in the
state
just now uh we just indicted uh the
perps gang in albany georgia this this
is a it was a list of 30 uh young men
from ages 12 to 26 and these kids are in
school etc and they all got indicted for
being in this gang and i think they may
have been responsible for killing the
nine-year-old in our city but these kids
can't read and write if i think if they
were at actual schools that were
teaching them what they need to know
such as our school teaching skilled
trades and and how to be a man and how
to you know
tie and how to talk to people etc they
would they wouldn't be in these areas
they wouldn't be uh living their lives
about to go to jail and throwing their
lives away at just 12 years old 13 years
old so you're expecting the kid that
can't read and write in a city with no
recreation etc to to go and be some type
of a great person that's absolutely
nonsense and these teachers who are
trying their hardest to to teach
differently but they're being handcuffed
by the system as well we have to get out
of that toxic relationship with our
systems and create systems of our own
you know all roads lead to bad
government government in general
government is rarely good
we got to stop the system we got to take
the power back and that's exactly what
you're doing king thanks so much for
joining me tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else